hello everyone
my name is samantha john and i'm one of
the
co-founders of hopscotch and
hopscotch is a programming language for
the ipad and
it's designed to help kids get started
with programming uh so
why why would i do such thing why would
i why do kids need to program
so there's this phrase tossed around
that
programming is the 21st century literacy
uh so you know the 13th century literacy
was
was a scribe and so this is
long ago before everyone knew how to
read
you would if you wanted to write a
letter to someone you would
go to a scribe and
they would write a letter for you you
would tell them what to write and you
would
send off that letter and the person who
got it would have to go to their own
scribe to read it
obviously things have changed since then
reading literacy
reading and writing is now kind of part
of our society
you can't really function if you don't
know how to read or write
you're you're going to be pretty lost
you know if you want to go buy a bottle
of shampoo
you better know how to read that word or
else you might end up with a bottle of
lotion
so fast forward to 2013
and now technology is everywhere
in the same way that for the last couple
hundred years reading and writing
the written word has been all around us
now
it's technology and if if you want to
change the radio station in your car
you need to use a computer or if you
need to find your way around a new city
you need to use a software program like
google maps or
apple maps maybe
and people these days
you people probably know how to use
technology pretty well
but a lot of people do not
and and that's a problem because
it's so much a part of our world and
it's actually the amount of people
learning how to do computer science
is declining but
the amount of people needed to do
computer sciences is increasing a lot
so this is this is a graph that shows
they expect 1.4 million new jobs in
computing
by 2020 and only 400 000 computer
science students
so that's a big gap and and if we don't
fill it there's going to be no one to
run our technology
and that's not good and
here's something else that's not good
does anyone know who this guy is
his anyone someone on the back does his
name is
sergey elenikov and he's a programmer
he was a programmer for goldman sachs
and he was the only person to go to jail
for the financial crisis
and he was sentenced to eight years in
prison because
he put some of his source code from
goldman sachs on a subversion repository
and he went on tr he was arrested by the
fbi he went to trial
and he was tried by a bunch of people
who
basically were high school graduates who
didn't really know anything about
technology
and they didn't understand
anything that was going on so they were
like yeah this
this crazy technologist he's guilty send
him away
and and luckily a year later his
conviction was overturned
by a judge who knew a little bit better
and she basically said
or he basically said that the laws that
the
crime the laws that they convicted of
him him of
didn't even apply to the case that he
was convicted of
um so it's kind of scary to think of uh
how much technology is important to our
world and how little people understand
so hopefully i've gotten you a little
bit
riled up about this so so what can you
do
well what i think you should do is teach
people how to program and
i skipped ahead a little bit but where
do you start how do you
start teaching people how to program how
do you start teaching kids how to
program that's
what we're talking about at hopscotch
although i
i do think these apply to everyone so um
if you know if
if anyone has any friends who who want
to learn how to program hopefully this
will also help them
um so
you know i don't know if anyone's ever
had an eight-year-old come up to them
and say
you know please sir i want some more
computer science
i haven't yet um
but that's not to say that learning code
can be exciting
and and what people actually want to do
is they don't want to learn computer
science
they want to make ipad apps they might
want to make iphone apps they want to
they want to change the world through
software and make things that people use
and that's very powerful i i know that
you know when i was in college i i
originally thought that
i would hate computer science and
and i i did my best to get out of all my
computer science classes even though i
was in engineering school
um till finally my senior year
i had this website i wanted to make and
no one would do it for me
so so i decided i had to i had to do it
myself
and and i learned php and i did it
myself
and it was like the best feeling in the
world
i was this little you know i was this
insignificant college student and
i was making something on the internet
that anyone could see and anyone could
use
and that was a wonderful feeling and and
kids can get that feeling too and any
beginner can get that feeling and i
think
that's really the feeling that sets off
the spark where
um where you're like yeah i do want to
learn to code
i want to learn how to do this so
uh what do we mean by learning to code
so at hopscotch um we're we're concerned
with
not necessarily turning people into
professional programmers
you know maybe like eight or nine is a
little young for that
maybe uh but
we want to make we want to um have kids
who use hopscotch to be proficient in
code be able to
kind of understand what's going on in
software and be able to build their own
things
um so so we like to think of it as
um knowing these four steps so
first being able to come up with an idea
um
knowing what tools you can use to solve
to
to implement your idea coming up with an
algorithm
and finally putting it into code
so i'm going to talk about each of these
four things i'm going to talk about
what i mean by it what what are the
pitfalls when you're trying to learn it
how does hopscotch solve it and then i'm
going to try and bring it back to the
real world a little bit
and you know some kids are too young to
actually
be on a computer so i want to talk a
little bit about
what can you do to prepare them for when
they are ready for the computer
so the first thing is an idea so you
can't really write a program if you
don't have an idea
you need to know what you're going to
make and
i forgot the order of myself so when you
when you ask most beginners
uh to come up with an idea of what they
want to program
you know it's usually something like
this you know i wanna i'm gonna have
someone like
take pictures of food and then i'm gonna
figure out how many calories are in that
food
and uh what ingredients and then i'm
gonna profit it's gonna it's gonna work
great
and and that's actually not a very good
idea
as a beginner or really i don't know
anyone who
is writing that software to find the
calories from a picture
um but they don't really know uh you
know what tools they have or
they don't know um what is really
available to them what's possible and
that really only comes with experience
um so
so my advice is if you're ever working
with a beginner it's probably best to
give them some ideas
because the ones they come up with
probably aren't going to be that good
or they're not going to be able to come
up with any um
you know i teach a lot of programming
workshops
both through hopscotch so teaching
hopscotch to kids or
i've taught some rails workshops and a
lot of times what happens is even the
most advanced students they'll
they'll be able to to do the thing that
we tell them to do
and then as soon as they finish they're
like what do i make next what's next
i'm like come up with something yourself
but
it's really it's hard for them so so i
really suggest kind of helping them out
with ideas
um and at hopscotch we try and
um give people sample projects so that
they can
to help them come up with ideas so this
is a truth or dare game
this goes a little fast um kind of like
spin the bottle but truth or dare
and um some kids took this and they
changed it around a little bit
um and they changed some of the words
and it became the who farted game
which is actually kind of more awesome
than truth or dare
so as long as you if you can give them
something to start
with often they can come up with ideas
but they do need that
first little push so i really recommend
with beginners
that you help them out a little bit
and then if you want to think about
maybe your kids a little too young for
hopscotch or
maybe you just want to get them off the
computer but still
uh thinking creatively and being and
working on being able to come up with
ideas
um so one thing i like is um how do i
get
oh here it is uh so have them make up
their own game
and and this is calvin ball which
i don't know if anyone knows the rules
to kelvin ball besides kelvin
but basically he's had to come up with
all the rules for his own game
and then he plays it and he sees how
well they work um
so i think that process of coming up
with the game
and then you know a game is fun so you
actually do want to test it
um you know because other ideas you
might be like oh i have this idea but i
can't really
do it so i think it's a good idea but if
you make a game then
you can just play your own game and see
how fun it is
and see how well it works um i also
think it would be really cool to make
your kid make their own board game and
like force them to come up with all the
rules and stuff
um but that might be harder to get them
to sit down and do
so the next topic i want to talk about
is
tools so um programming your tools
are your computer that's probably your
most important tool because that's going
to run all your code
and also your programming language um
so kind of the first thing you have to
understand
is your computer and how it works so
you know computers are kind of dumb
compared to a human
so like if if your mom tells you you
know do
this this and this and this you know
tells you six things to do
um you can probably figure out what is
the most reasonable order to do them in
and like what's the best way to do them
and
and go from her kind of vague
instructions and um
and come up with the specifics yourself
but a computer won't really do that
a computer will basically do exactly
what you tell it to do
in the order you tell it to do it and
nothing more nothing less
and um really like internalizing that i
think is
is kind of the first step for beginners
because
um you know as i was talking about ideas
i said that that's kind of
even though that's the first thing you
need to write a program i think that's
kind of the last thing you learn
so learning about how to use your tools
is really like
kind of where you start when you're
teaching someone
so once you understand this kind of idea
of sequencing and the idea that
computers are going to be very literal
and do only what you tell them
um the kind of next next thing that
you should be learning are the kind of
computer science like primitives
and so those are things like loops and
variables and if else statements and all
the sort of basic building blocks
of a programming language
and just understanding how those works
how those
work and how they can work together um
so our curriculum designer came up with
this
with this little graphic so loops and
lists are best friends
and you probably actually already knew
that you probably know that like
whenever you have a list
you're probably gonna have to use a loop
at some point
to iterate over it um but you don't
think of it so literally but
but for a beginner this isn't
necessarily obvious and and they need to
learn all of these connections
um so it's first of all very important
to
to get them comfortable with the tools
so you know
have have the person learning uh play
with
lists play with loops and and have them
kind of
uh just practice but i think it's also
really important and this is something
that a lot of um
computer science teaching neglects to
come to try and figure out
what tools are right for what problem
um often like if you look at an ap
computer science
question or something like that uh
they'll
kind of tell you exactly what tools to
use they'll be like you know
make this text parser that uses um this
kind of text box
as the input and then puts it out as
like a message view
and um and uses a string and uses
whatever
um but i think it's much more
interesting much more useful
to um to kind of leave that up to the to
the student
and and work with them to try and figure
out what is the best tool so a better
assignment would be like
you know make a slot machine and what do
you need to make a slot machine and kind
of
talk through all of those things because
in the real world it's not like
you caught you're like i want to make
this app and
and then there's no second step where
someone tells you to use a linked list
and to use and tells you what to use you
have to figure that out yourself
um so that's kind of a really important
thing to learn
um so so with tools this is actually
something
that hopscotch and other visual
programming languages
do really well um so
we the nice thing about a visual
programming language is that
all the tools are there in the interface
for you to look at
so in the sidebar we have this library
of the available methods that you can
use
and you can kind of collapse or expand
them
depending on what you're using there's
also
a like this little event drop down that
has all these cool
ipad native events i couldn't figure out
how to hook up my ipad but
um there's there's like some fun demos i
can do with that so if anyone wants to
see me after i can show you
like the cool things you can do with
like
tilting or using the microphone input on
your ipad
and one interesting thing we found is
that as their users get more advanced
they take the tools that we gave them
and they use them in unexpected ways
so we purposely only let people use
these characters that we
we came up with and that our illustrator
drew
because we wanted to keep a consistent
look we wanted their programs to
actually look nice
i don't know if anyone has ever used
scratch from mit
anyone almost everyone so scratch is
awesome we
are definitely very inspired by scratch
but one thing they do is they have this
huge library of art that you can use and
by art
i mean there's like clip art and then
there's also
like photo cutouts of people
and there's all this just really weird
stuff that doesn't go together at all
and we were kind of like we want
hopscotch users to only make things that
go together and look nice
um but they actually kind of foiled us
because
we let them make a text object and um
and they they came up with all these
like funky things you could do with text
um so someone made the solar system
we didn't give them any planets but they
just use
these letters
and oh whoops i'll keep the solar system
up for a second um
and another thing people did was um they
used emojis
turns out you can just blow up emojis
and they look like art kind of
um so people use that to add different
characters that they didn't have so
it was both a little distressing and
pretty awesome that
people were able to give take this
limited tool set that we gave them
and use it in unexpected ways
uh so lastly about using tools in the
real world i think
these kind of like crazy art sets that
have like everything you can imagine
they're like a really good learning tool
in that you have to you have all these
choices of things you could use
and and you have to pick the best one
and
the best one is not the same for every
situation so
you know if you want to make a poster to
bring to the hockey game
you know maybe like colored pencils
aren't aren't the right tool
maybe maybe you want some thick markers
but then maybe you want to make like an
impressionist landscape
of your front yard and then maybe you
want to use like some watercolors and
not
maybe skip out on the crayons um so
i think that this is something that
really maps well to the real world and
so learning about how to pick the right
tools
in computer science actually you know
helps you out in the real world
uh when you have to pick the right tools
for your art project and
and vice versa um so this is this is
actually i think a very
useful skill
uh so after you've figured out kind of
what tools you need
um the next the next important thing to
do
is figure out your algorithm and
algorithms i think are
are the thing that's like most famous
about computer science like everyone
knows about algorithms
you know like this is an algorithm maybe
and um they also i think part of that is
that they map really well to the real
world
um you know you can you can have an
algorithm to make money on wall street
um and and if you have one tell me
uh and or you can you can have an
algorithm to do your
taxes um so i think this kind of makes a
lot of sense to people
and an important thing about algorithms
is that in order to
write one you have to kind of put
yourself in the computer's place
and learn how to think like a computer
which
which actually like takes some practice
um
so that's kind of the important thing
about algorithms
so with hopscotch we used a lot
of the kind of ideas from from seymour
paper who who wrote this language called
logo
some people have talked about it in
other talks
so these characters are kind of like the
logo turtle
and um they can
you can write an algorithm and see
visually whether it worked and
how it messed up or how it did well
and this is this is actually from a
workshop we did with kids at
this thing called the lab miami and
that's their logo
so we asked all the kids to to kind of
create their own
algorithm to to do the logo of the lab
miami
and if you saw earlier in the video
there was like a completely different
looking logo than this one and and some
people did it with lots of different
characters
making the logo simultaneously so it was
a little faster
so so people came up even though they
all had the same idea to start with they
came up with a lot of
different really creative algorithms
which was really cool to see
so so the real world way to learn
algorithms there's a lot of real-world
ways but
i think this game is really fun for kids
it's called program your parent
and and it's not really a game but it's
basically you let the kid
uh tell you what to do and i think kids
like that a lot i think they like
telling adults what to do
and but the catch is they have to
you can't they can't just tell you to
make a sandwich because you don't know
how to make a sandwich
so they have to tell you every little
step along the way
and teach you how to make a sandwich um
so basically they have to cut if they
want to make you do something they have
to come up with an algorithm to make you
do it
um so this is a good thing to try out if
your kids a little too young to program
or
just in daily life
uh so the very last step of creating a
computer program
is the actual code and this is where you
put your algorithm
to not to paper to computer and um
and make it work uh
but there is a problem which is that
code is really scary
um i don't know if anyone here is an ios
developer but
uh this is xcode this is the this is
actually hopscotch code
uh except it's totally terrifying
there's like
all these little red exclamation marks
on the side
and there's all this text on the bottom
and it's it feels very opaque and
and very intimidating um
and and code is kind of where where you
things start to go wrong
i think um and it's unfortunately a lot
of the time where people start
like if you use like codecademy or khan
academy or those things you have to
start out by typing in your code before
you really
thought about all the other things that
that you need to think about
um so i think this is one of the things
that can turn people off to
off to computer science really fast is
when
they start writing some code and the
first thing they do is fail
and usually the first thing they do is
fail because
people who aren't programmers are really
bad
at typing programs which
you know it's kind of fair because i
don't know when the last time i used a
curly brace
in my regular writing was but it's
probably when i was writing a blog post
about programming
and and even worse um if there's any
kids in the room cover your ears
um kids can't type
um that's why they take typing class
they're really bad they're really slow
and um so if you're trying to teach kids
to code
and you and you're like okay type this
in and you expect them to type it in and
they're like
i can't find the z on the keyboard
and you're like oh we're we're working
at a different level than i thought here
um
so that's something that hopscotch
really tries to address so hot scotch is
not scary
um so you make a little new project this
is coding in hopscotch where you're
gonna make a circle
and all you have to do is drag and drop
these nice friendly little blocks around
um they're colorful and and you can't
really get
error messages like you're not going to
get a seg fault or like an
you know a named parameter or anything
like that because
it just kind of works i mean you might
not program the thing you thought you
were programming
but you will program something
um so this is a little circle it took me
a really long time to calculate how many
repeats i needed
see a little cupcake drawing a circle
and hopefully that felt really friendly
and you felt like oh i could do that
i mean i guess you guys are programmers
so maybe you felt like that when you saw
objective co2
so um but hopefully anyone would feel
like
they could do that and that it would be
fun
[Applause]
so coding is like kind of hard to think
of a real world example because
coding is like by its nature it's so
much on the computer
but actually if anyone's ever done any
knitting
knitting patterns are actually a lot
like coding
they're basically it's like an algorithm
and you
are the computer you the knitter are the
computer and you have to follow the
instructions exactly and then you will
come out with beautiful fair isle
sweater
and actually like people who knit turn
out to often be really good coders
our curriculum designer was was working
with girls who code this summer
and she told me that her best student
was this girl who is also an avid
crocheter
and crochet patterns are similar except
that they're all text
so so they actually are words that say
what you should be doing
and for her final project she made this
a little uh like a rebel for
for crochet patterns where you could
type in a crochet pattern
and press play and it would show you
what it would look like it had you
crocheted it
which is sweet because apparently for
crochet books
they have to hire like five people to
make every pattern to make sure it works
and then she just did it in code so this
is a high school girl who
had never coded in her life before this
summer and then all she had been doing
is crocheting
so teach her kids to knit
so in conclusion i hope you guys have
all
picked up some tips about how best to
teach people to code and how best to
teach kids to code
and i hope that you go out in the world
now and tell people to use hopscotch or
tell people to use scratch tell people
to learn how to code
and that you've realized how important
it is and how much better people's lives
would be if they knew how to code
because it's really fun
and then i just want to say thanks the
people who helped me a lot
ashley gavin jocelyn levitt peter bell
and steve
ellis now if there are any questions
i can answer them yeah
um so it looks like uh hopscotch
develops applications fronton and ipad
what things have you what are you
projecting with it next
okay so the question yeah the question
was uh hopscotch right now is on the
ipad what do you
what are you guys going to do next uh
our current plans are to continue
working on the ipad application
uh we have a lot of ideas for how to
make it better for how to
help people come up with more ideas and
help people learn better on the app
we also would love to make an android
version uh once we have the bandwidth
we actually don't want to do it on the
computer uh
i don't know if for people who've used
scratch i think it becomes a little bit
tedious sometimes to be dragging and
dropping so much
you're kind of like i wish i could just
type this because that would be faster
but actually on a on a tablet device it
turns out that
you don't really get sick of dragging
and dropping things it feels much nicer
it's
it's it feels like the natural
interaction and you you actually
would rather do that than type unless
maybe you have a keyboard attached
but that's kind of a different story
two systems or more systems to interact
oh
[Music]
yeah we okay so he asked if we would be
having multiple systems interact
we really want to do like hardware
integrations
so there's a lot of bluetooth technology
coming out and
the new iphones i think have this not
near field but something similar
beacon so i think there's a lot of
opportunities to work with
other other like toys and be able to
program them
using hopscotch um i think there it
would also be very cool if people
could program um hot scotches that could
you know hit apis on a server or that
could maybe interact with one another
maybe like
pokemon or something you can play
pokemon against one another right
i don't know that was a long time ago uh
are you in the red about
kids being bad typing was really
interesting
as being a barrier to learning the
program but
sort of that side you know if you have a
certain level
of you know sort of typing ability type
of literacy
um do you know of studies on
kids that compare between saying a
teaching
hit list which has
[Music]
what sort of research do you do to
evaluate how well your
so the question is is there any research
about teaching kids
a typed programming language such as
lisp versus a visual programming
language
uh that's a good question and i i don't
know of any but
i'll look for it and i'll post it on
twitter
my findings but i have seen that at the
harvard
uh introduction to computer science
class they're using scratch actually for
the first
three weeks of class and
you know anecdotally and from uh you
know talking to
people who have done a lot of teaching i
think
co like the even if you can type
uh even if you are like a relatively
good typer just
like the over the mental overhead of of
learning so much syntax while at the
same time learning so many new concepts
can be really challenging so being able
to just
focus on learning the concepts separate
from learning the syntax
can be really helpful when you're
starting out
yeah i thought it was interesting when
you said when you're talking about
the heart set and having like a large
number of tools to choose from where a
lot of maybe
more advanced people would like put
arbitrary restrictions on themselves
like yeah
make this work on apple 2 or something i
was only just like
do you think those are helpful for the
kids
okay so the question was um what
is would there be an advantage of
limiting your tool set so there's a
really large art set but maybe
sometimes experts will say we have this
really large art set but i'm only going
to use crayons
or some something of that nature uh and
i think that can be really i think that
can be really helpful for creativity to
um to kind of put some arbitrary
arbitrary limits on yourself
because then you're you're working
within a smaller system rather than
trying to imagine the possibilities
among the whole world
um so yeah i think that can be really
helpful and that's something
we've actually talked about doing with
hopscotch is giving people challenges
with a limited number of methods and not
letting them use everything at once
in order to kind of spark their
creativity
uh
so the question is what age range are we
targeting probably
eight or nine and above uh we've
definitely seen kids younger than that
but the younger kids tend to i think
they don't have the capacity as much to
think in the future
so they tend to just kind of randomly
put methods
into the script and then see what
happens
and they're usually pretty entertained
by what happens but they're not
necessarily coming up with an idea and
executing on it
uh yeah i like your example that's right
and the difference between reading and
writing
and coding is really writing about with
us for a thousand years even more
while coding is fairly immature within
50 years
so don't you think rather than pushing
us towards the machine
would be better bring machine towards us
so
so the question was or he said that
reading and writing had evolved
with people uh over a long time so maybe
what we should be doing is evolving
coding rather than evolving people
uh and i think that's a good point i
think that there's a lot of um
a lot of things coming out to make kind
of understanding technology easier
we hope that hopscotch is one of them
there's also like if this than that
to kind of introduce people to these
topics without
um without the kind of really
challenging
like syntax heavy type like
configuration heavy type of environments
um you with your hand raised really high
yeah uh he asked if i'd seen kodia kodia
is a
ipad app that you can program lua
on your ipad and it has a lot of has a
lot of nice
little uh editor features like there's a
color picker and
and various like inline help type things
codia is really cool i think that even
even from what i've seen of it now you
kind of have to know lua
beforehand before it's really going to
be useful but if you do know
lua and you have i think you also
probably have to have an external
keyboard
um because it's it's still pretty hard
to type on your ipad that much
but i think within those constraints it
can be really awesome so
i would definitely recommend it as kind
of a next step after hopscotch
if you're getting if your kid is getting
really good at programming
um uh you with the red hair
um with
children i was curious like what kind of
methodologies
you found effective or ineffective uh in
working on teaching this
like in a group setting like uh like did
the kids
pair on working with it or is it uh do
you leave the
ipad in the room in kind of a directed
montessori style
kind of like environment like what is
probably the most effective
so the question is what's been effective
at teaching hopscotch in group settings
well a lot of the time we don't have
enough ipads for everyone so they
actually have to pair
but i think pairing has worked really
well and i found that just to be a
really
effective learning tool in general
um although sometimes there's like the
kid who hogs the ipad
but i think people have a lot of fun
working in groups and kids like to be
social and
hang out with each other um one thing
that worked really well is
we would um we would put an ipad on
airplay and so we'd have it on a big
screen and then
um sometimes we would sometimes we would
just show them a project
we would show them in the end result of
a project and say can you do this
and kids tended to have a lot of fun
with that and then if you just go around
the room and kind of
unblock people it works pretty well
but i think the most important thing is
having a good supply of
ideas of things for people to make if
you just kind of let them loose with the
ipad immediately
i think they have a hard time deciding
what to do with it
um all the way in the back
uh can you give any suggestions more
generally
good resources for
uh so good resources for teaching
and pedagogy uh i really like uh
seymour papert's book mindstorms
i highly recommend that to anyone who
wants to teach kids
i like brett victor's work a lot it's
not
directly related but he writes a lot
about creating interfaces
that will help people program better
especially beginners
uh we're also hopscotch is in the
process of
publishing some curriculum so
please feel free to get in touch with me
on twitter by email
or just talk to me after and i can give
you some previews of those curriculums
what's the name of that paper you
mentioned uh the paper
yeah oh seymour paper p it's p-a-p-e-r-t
it's his name and the book is called
mindstorms
like lego mindstorms
yeah um so
i'm guessing most people here wouldn't
have any trouble
teaching their kids using something like
hopscotch or something
what can we do for
children who don't have parents who are
programmers
like what can people in this room do to
help kids who wouldn't have that support
in the home
that's so what can you do to help kids
who don't have
awesome parents who are programmers
um well i have a friend who is
who has actually started an after-school
uh programming class
at at his kids school uh so if you have
the time to do something like that
i think stuff like that is always really
wonderful uh there's also
coder dojo which is this fantastic
organization
it's all over the world it started in
ireland and
basically they host uh like kind of free
coding sessions for kids of all ages to
come in and
and learn some programming and i've been
involved with the new york coder dojo
and it's been really successful so
starting a coder dojo in your
neighborhood is a really great way to
get kids interested and give them some
exposure
i just think that kids tend to
gravitate to their moms so teach your
wife how to code
she'll teach some other women for every
woman who learns the thing
you actually end up teaching six people
because the woman will teach five other
people
teach women how to code the whole world
teach women how to code the whole world
learns exactly
i love it uh yeah um
thank you for doing this i think you
have a lot of excited parents
have you thought about games for even
younger kids that are just
really simple that may teach even an
inkling of an idea
for example i have a three-year-old who
i just noticed started sorting things by
colors
i would love if there was a touchscreen
game where he could just
even sort by colors and maybe a next
step
after that okay so games and
apps for kids who are too young for
hopscotch like three or four-year-olds
uh i've seen there's a thing called
codable with a k
i it still might be a little bit old but
i think it's a little bit simpler than
hopscotch
um and at hopscotch we actually are the
very first thing we did before we
even it was like a side project before
we had even
left our jobs to do it full-time we have
this app called daisy the dinosaur
which is aimed at slightly younger kids
and it's a programming app where you
program this dinosaur to
to do various dances and and the like
um there's also this kickstarter that's
gotten a lot of attention called
uh robot turtles i think and it's a
board game to teach kids programming i
haven't actually used it but it seems
really awesome
uh yeah yeah i come to a school where
we have good luck sort of
pre-programming instead
using crazy machines
it's a kind of a wall
that you have various gizmos okay you
plug them together and do various things
and maybe you don't have enough cord to
get the
fan all you have to get like
the light bulb lit up but you don't have
enough cord but you have a
fan and a generator which has a like
that's awesome so crazy machines and i
actually think there's an ipad app
called
tinkerbox which is a little bit similar
i think is along those same concepts so
maybe that
also could work yeah
what inspired me to want to help kids it
well
to be perfectly honest i was kind of
inspired to help girls
uh but then we decided that all kids
could
use it too
and i mean it was pretty natural for me
because i was a girl in the sciences
and i kind of saw that you know in
middle school there were tons of girls
in math class and even in high school
it didn't really i didn't really notice
that girls were worse at math than boys
and then all of a sudden in college it
was like
i was only girl and um
so i started thinking about how why is
this and how can we solve it
and kind of came to hopscotch eventually
yeah yeah so
kids i should um encourage everybody to
like play board games with
kids i mean i've had two kids who are
four and six they're obsessed with this
game
called mice and mystics which is which
is like it's a ridiculously complex game
relatively but it's you know this
dungeon crawl adventure
that's cooperative where your kids are
mice and they're you know fighting
spiders and stuff
in a castle and things like that where
you know
if i come home at night and they're like
can we play myself
is one where it's very much about you
have to think about okay
this card is going to make the robot go
forward this card is going to make robot
turn right
okay cool so he said good things for
kids are board games
and such as mice and mystics and robo
rally games where you're not playing
against them
so cooperative game's also good yeah
uh yeah so uh have you heard have you
heard of scs
the cs unplugged curriculum
i haven't so it's basically an entire
curriculum that's aimed at
kids high school-aged kids that teach
computer science
without programming so for instance
so cs unplugged also a great resource
that i will have to check out myself
uh okay i think it looks like time is up
so
thank you everyone for coming